[Music]
so that to me is the best argument for a
free market your own interest if you own
a restaurant it's not that the inspector
is gonna force you to do it or that the
government comes in or as you said you
can pay them off and all this stuff but
the best is that your reputation of
course the the caring of your work which
is a great segue to I won't talk about
virtue well that's why we by the way
that's why we need a free press that's
why this these movements in in Russia
and now in Turkey an imitation of Russia
to close down the newspapers is a
complete disaster for the ordinary
people where do you think that puts us
in America right now because well carp
has this massive fight with the press I
know it does it as an alternate press
guy as a digital online guy I see a lot
of value in what he's doing and at the
same time I absolutely see the risk
unless it's completely he's a danger to
the First Amendment but fortunately the
the genie is out of the bottle you can't
put it back in so far as electronic
media is concerned the newspapers are
slowly descending which I you know
personally I love him happy in this
paper but ok it's it's like the
invention of the printing press in many
countries although not all of them the
printing press was very hard to control
and now it's even less easy to control
the internet yeah the Chinese do a
fairly good job of it but when I was in
China a month ago the my friends told me
oh you're here to sell you yours how you
get around that and it it was free you
could you could do it and sneak around
the wall so the great wall was probably
more effective the great wall was
surprisingly effective actually its
purpose was to slow down the barbarians
long enough to bring reinforcements
yeah I don't know if the reinforcements
are gonna come in time to stop his
barrage that was the big problem every
two two or three hundred years in China
the great wall defense would fail
yeah there's some parallel to the
internet while there is there's
what there is is that the cost of
Liberty is constant vigilance because
it's the it's in the interest of the
government more or less every time to
cut off free speech and if they can get
away with it they will no matter who
more or less no matter who's in charge
yeah Obama who I didn't vote for but I
don't think it's the Antichrist as some
of my conservative friends think claimed
that he was going to have an open
government no way Jose he kept closing
it yeah and and he but that happens in
every ministration yeah so it's it just
happened no matter what they say before
he like when he said you know Obamacare
we're gonna air the hearings over on
c-span right of course that didn't
happen he's jailed whistleblowers look
up look at Snowden and yet the left lets
him off the hook on that because we've
all been just sort of relegated to our
teams right you just picture I know I
know it's because people come to their
political opinions in their late
teenagehood most of them mm-hmm and then
it becomes part of their personal
identity I have a roommate of mine oh
man who I loved very much from college
and he was a lefty as I was in college
and he still is you know he still he and
then my sister my beloved sister I
really do love the other day the other
month she said you know I watch RT
Russia today yeah and I think that's
just great they give me an alternative
view I said dear don't you know this is
Putin's propaganda arm yeah oh really oh
I don't think so I think it's wonderful
what they do so people get these
identities of left and right
hmm and that may don't ever listen to
any more evidence the another hero of my
youth John Maynard Keynes was someone
complained that it changed came
had changed his views on free trade to
which Keynes said when I get new
information I changed my mind what do
you do which is anything that true
liberalism right of course of that that
that finding open my issues and you know
Bertrand Russell there's that great
quote about you know not being tied to
an ideology but but to reality except he
was - except for that probably the the
the the perfect example of this is John
Stuart Mill who was very open-minded he
was open-minded - socialist ideas
Harriet Harriet his his friend
eventually became his wife what was more
of a socialist this is the middle of the
19th century and so he was very open to
that so someone's been a great great
economist friend of mine said John
Stuart Mill tried the experiment of
being fair to his opponents this
experiment has never again been done
economics yeah in economics we're almost
in any field anymore there's look the
assumption on the left in the United
States among progressives is it if you
make a free-market argument it's because
you're a bad person who hates poor
people yeah and so why pay attention to
such a person
why pay attention to Hitler Hitler may
have arguments tell with I'm not gonna
listen to Hitler I don't listen I don't
say oh gee that's interesting let's
exterminate the Jews maybe that'll be a
good idea no I don't I don't view that
as on the table mm-hmm so it's this off
the table business that makes our
friends on the Left impervious to any
argument we make arguments against I
don't know against the minimum wage or
agriculture or look it's talking to a
friend of mine on the Left the other day
and she said I'm very suspicious of this
uber business breaking down the taxicab
monopoly I said what you mean you're in
favor of taxi monopolies do you know who
owns those she said no I don't know
isn't it the cab drivers no it's not
it's the millionaire's the
millionaires who own 30 hack medallions
in New York each of which sells for a
million and a half bucks yeah you're not
making that up by the way that's
actually true that that medallion that
you have driver needs them in Chicago
you know so it's so strange
any free-market argument it's just off I
think the the image of being off the
table is correct it's just not for
discussion so it's maddening we on on
the free-market side you know we
laborious ly argue against this stupid
regulation and that stupid regulation we
offer facts and we have comparisons of
one country to another and we're very
earnest and we expect our friends on the
left no they don't
yeah they don't listen so they don't
understand the arguments a spectacular
example of the bottom of page six in the
English translation of tomorrow my
piketty's book on capital in the 21st
century
where he screws up supply demand curves
I mean he really does he doesn't
understand supply response to a higher
price he doesn't even think it's
possible so this guy is an economist
yeah maybe he wrote the book upside down
I don't know what is what wrong with him
no I'm actually I know it's wrong he was
he was educated in France and in
economics that means you're educated in
mathematics without knowing anything
about how an economy works so I plead
with them please and they won't listen
so what do you do then if well first of
I know a certain amount of people are
gonna watch this and say wait a minute
then Deirdre must be right because you
focused on left here that's it right
yeah and it's just not that's how people
can do we say we real liberals say to
look there to at least two dimensions
one is is
is economic freedom left right B that's
pretty easy to talk about and the other
is personal freedom left right and we
libertarians are up on the left left
quadrant right we believe in keeping out
of people's bedrooms and keeping out of
people's voluntary deals in the economy
it's a keeping out mentality what's the
beef here why are you complaining about
some deal I want to make shut up it's
none of your business let's just make it
and that's it and and so we're we we
believe in freedom where as in one
aspect or another our opponents whether
Republicans or Democrats or
conservatives or progressives they all
believe in compulsion they'll believe in
getting out the government gun forcing
people to do things yeah and I think
that's going to make the world better
and you know it actually make the world
more resentful I think usually it does
now look there there are some things
always it's so tedious I always get
people my progressive friends will say
oh don't you think there should be a
role for government and I say yeah yeah
there's be role for government
preventing force and fraud and a few
other things so basically you're not an
anarchist although we real true
Christian liberals view our anarchist
friends and I have some with a certain
sisterly sympathy but I'm not an
anarchist I don't believe in zero
government actually my first politics
was when I found Prince Kropotkin book
mutual aid in the local Carnegie Library
I like the irony of that in Wakefield
Massachusetts and for you know six
months when I was fifteen I was an
anarchist yeah
how those things might go for you well I
didn't tell anyone it didn't bother
anyone
right you just know I wasn't secret
about it I just didn't notice that
politics was about telling people stuff
yeah all right so I want to I want to
back up to virtue because I think it's
it's sort of a through-line in almost
everything we've discussed yesterday and
you've written a lot about it you talked
about it and I think it's something
that's so missing in society that is
doing something virtuous just you know
and I've been I've been studying China
for the last ten years a bit for a long
time I tried not to because I knew I
would become fascinated and I needed to
know more about Europe in the United
States
it's afraid I would be drift off into
China studies but the interesting thing
about the Confucian attitudes it started
in the sixth century BCE is that it
claims that the main protection of the
citizens is the virtue of the governors
and that's correct to the extent that
they're being treated by the government
and the Confucians were not particularly
didn't have a lot to say about
regulation of the economy so you know
they have the economy off to one side
and indeed it was heavily regulated and
China as everywhere else but let's talk
about the relationship between the
government the Emperor and the citizens
and the Confucian idea is not balance of
power of the founding fathers where
we're trying to make a machinery that
will keep people keep the governors from
hurting their citizens which is what we
have here what we have here and we try
to make it work and I'm all for it
because but they the Confucians like the
so-called civic republicans in europe
and in the 17th and 18th century said
look rulers need to be good as well that
and i think this is true and look the
corruption in italy say you're not going
to solve italian corruption
another law they got laws against
corruption right the problem is the laws
will actually breed more corruption I
breathe nobody do this easily do it
particularly if the ethical mentality of
Italian says the government is a band of
robbers into his clutches we fall into
quote a famous anarchist writer and so
we've got to evade every law we can and
as long as you do that as long as the
people are not being virtuous sensibly
following the sensible laws and the
government is not being virtuous it's
stealing from everybody you know passing
another things for Parliament isn't
going to have any effect at all so there
has to be an ethical change and I claim
this is my big claim in this this
trilogy of mine called the bourgeois era
which I praise the Lord I just finished
last spring that it's a change in
attitudes towards the virtues of the
bourgeoisie that made the modern world
that up until liberalism
the coming of liberalism in people's
heads in the 18th century and then in
actual policies in the 19th century
until that happened people were
extremely suspicious and hostile towards
merchants manufacturers in fetters
innovation the word innovation in
English was until the 19th century a bad
word you don't want to innovate innovate
that'll disturb things that babies say
that was the universal attitude and then
in in liberalism basic idea of which is
let people alone as Adam Smith said what
we need is the liberal plan of
equality liberty and justice equality he
didn't mean equal income distribution
of social standing by live Liberty meant
the ability to start a business or
become an economist or whatever he wants
volley of opportunity quality of
opportunity and justice means equal
justice before the law neither which is
perfectly obtained in any society I know
of but the change from say the 17th
century to the 19th century was dramatic
mhm
and that made people bold and they
enriched us all I speak of the bourgeois
deal you let me a bush was startup
business and in the first act I'll make
a lot of dough it's a good business the
second I think these pesky competitors
will come in drive out my profit but
well the third act
I'll enrich you and that's what they did
so there's an ethical change wait how do
you get from the second act to the third
X to the second act now the Competition
Commission you're built so my profits
are eroded so everyone's doing it the
better way whatever it is uber or
improved look what happened to film when
I was young Kodak boom suddenly we had
had pixels yeah and now we're doing on
the you know we're doing I don't know
how it's happening but it's happening
here we are yeah so the third act then
is that the product itself gets exactly
those cameras that are pointing at us
are by historical standards are
ridiculously small yeah
these are high quality cameras that do a
is as good a job as an enormous TV
camera much better job than a TV camera
and even better than a great big film
camera in the 1930s mmm-hmm
and there they are and that's the first
person to think of this made a ton of
money but actually in the end the
inventors don't make that much they make
about two percent of the social gain
which you know if you're if you're Steve
Steve Jobs is a lot
but still 98% goes to us the consumers
right and bring this around to Apple
they make a lot of the stuff the ideas
come from Cupertino as they always tell
us yeah but a lot of it's made in China
and don't they do everything they can to
avoid corporate taxes of course sort of
ties in everything that's me that's this
there's a crazy regulation that the EU
the Common Market is trying to impose to
equalize corporate taxes across the EU
mm-hmm because they don't like what
Ireland's doing she has a 15 percent no
12 and a half percent corporate tax
instead of our 35 percent corporate tax
and the the people in in Brussels are
really annoyed it if the Irish and I
think it's outrageous that they're sure
there should be the Cayman Islands
there should be competition the
government shouldn't have us as serfs to
extract money from anytime they want to
invade Iraq yeah both Anna is I always
find to be the funniest argument is that
the progressives argue that they want
that the government is deeply corrupt
and I know and then at the same time
their response is to make it big I know
I know this look I've spent some time in
in Italy in the last few months and I
love Italy who doesn't the Italians know
how to live but they all ought to be
classical liberals because any sentient
Italian knows that sending more money
and power to Rome is a terrible idea
just awful
framed with that saying Rome actually
adds to the well it's like Washington or
very Springfield in Illinois everyone
knows it's a terrible idea
yep the Italians keep voting for
socialists or for conservatives who are
actually socialists yeah I mean I can't
understand it and in Sweden I get it
I I've taught in Sweden and I and I like
Sweden a lot lots of friends there and
they all tell me well
our government is honest and I say yeah
yours is Minnesota is but Illinois isn't
Italy isn't 86% of the people of the
world are governed by governments that
everyone would agree are completely
corrupt and incompetent the Italians of
180 or so governments that were surveyed
the Italians ranked 75th and yet they
keep voting for more of this I don't
know what to do I'm dead serious
yeah I wish I had an answer for you but
you're not gonna get it to me there's
there's so much more that we could do
here but I will end on something that
you slipped in once or twice is that you
used to be a Marxist I was the word
Marxist I think people have no idea what
they're talking about like socialism
they don't know what they're talking
about
most of these words most people don't
know what they're talking about but
Marxist I find to be the one that people
really just have no concept yeah of
whether you're talking about so first
can you just define what a Marxist is
and then just tell me a little bit about
your journey well a Marxist really in
the simplest terms is some who fathers I
want to follows Marx just as I'm a
Christian I follow Christ Marx was
here's where I get my right wing friends
just they go nuts
I say Marx was the greatest social
scientist in the 19th century without
compare and all my friends would be at
the Hoover Institution God and then I
say but he got everything wrong and then
my friends on the Left which is why I
haven't got any friends the life of a
classical liberal it ain't easy what
you're pissing off people aren't people
on both sides now the basic idea of
Marxism of course is it history has a
particular pattern and that ideas come
from that pattern from that material
pattern that the class struggle is
central the history of all hitherto
existing societies to quote the
Communist Manifesto is the history of
class struggle and if you believe that
and you believe that
ideas are just epiphenomena that they
just come from your class position which
is what work cysts are supposed to think
then you'll be a follower of Marx and
oddly from about 1890 to about 1980 nice
symmetry there most intellectuals in the
West were some kind of Marxist even the
Conservatives were even the
Conservatives believe that material
interests were what determined ideas
where is my claim and the claim of a
growing number of historians and
especially historians is it no no ideas
themselves have an influence and an
independent influence and the idea that
all men and and women dare are created
equal is a is a terrifically powerful
idea so it's that egalitarianism of 18th
century liberalism but I'm trying to
reinvigorate yeah well I think you're
doing an incredibly good job at it and I
mean my books you got to mention my but
yeah well I'm gonna tell people about
Twitter and the whole thing so this so
the bourgeois we've been yeah this is
the first book yeah the book about
burgers yeah and there's burgeois
dignity and then the last one is the
thickest called Bush way quality yeah
1906 sorry 6 2010 2016 all available at
the University of Chicago Press I'm
hoping for a box set
like Harry Potter I was we have them
together oh I'm a Star Wars guy
personally but that works for you makes
wonderful Christmas presents your mother
would be delighted to get these very
easily academic books well you know what
we're gonna put the link right down
below and people will just be able to
click it and get it it really was a
pleasure talking to you and you know
these are the ideas I'm trying to get
across to so I guess we're gonna have
people we're stuck in the middle but
never stuck in the middle grid we get
unfriendly fire from both sides yeah but
we got each other there you go all right
well I want to thank Deirdre McCloskey
and learn liberty for sending her our
way
and for more on Deirdre you can follow
her on the Twitter it's at Deirdre
McCloskey and thanks for watching we'll
do it again next week
you